ce n'est tout bon jour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord peut-on parler d'une
décision politique de la part de londres
alors tout à fait pour moi la première
chose c'est interroge c'est que déjà
comment on a pu en arriver là c'est à
dire comment un pays comme la chine a pu
devenir le seul producteur on va dire
actifs pour ce type de technologie et
c'est assez intéressant parce que
justement l'angleterre ça fait partie
des pays qui ont toutes ces âmes et
prenez le libéralisme la globalisation
et celles qui ont donné cette puissance
à la chine donc aujourd'hui dans une
volonté on va dire de s'aligner sur les
états unis puisque avec le bric site les
amers des anglais veulent se rapprocher
des américains là c'est même
désespérément alors que des américains
n'ont pas forcément l'air très enclin à
faire ce rapprochement là ils suivent
cette on va dire cette course à
l'échalote que faire donald trump sur la
chine et de surtout depuis le corps n'a
virus il faut pas oublier quand je suis
aux états unis on appelle le coronavirus
le gyrus chinois et donc ça me rappelle
dans mon enfance il y avait le secret de
l'espadon où il y avait la chine qui
envahissait tout le monde comme ça et on
va dire si on les écoute on est un peu
dans cette logique là alors que la
réalité c'est que la chine est devenu
hégémonique sur la production
industrielle de nouvelles technologies
puisque les iphone sont produits en
chine aussi est que comme tout pays
on va dire avec cette puissance
économique c'est normal qu'ils
deviennent dangereux et on va dire aucun
pays n'a réussi à atteindre une hymne
aux gémonies aussi importante
commercialement en distribuant des
bonbons ou des peluches
c'est à dire que la guerre commerciale
ça fait partie qu'est-ce que derrière
les experts nous parle
la vraie question c'est plutôt ça m'a
jamais gêné le royaume uni que cisco
alors qu'on a de nombreux documents
là-dessus donné par edouard snowdon
julian assange sur la question de
l'espionnage industriel d
société américaine au profit de la nsa
s'est jamais gêné il ya quand même une
base échelons autour du programme de
surveillance globale dans le yorkshire
et mais si c'est les chinois qui
espionnent a tout de suite ça les
préoccupent
or pour moi s'il ya une vraie
préoccupation sur la question de la
surveillance globale
on pourrait se poser la question de
l'hypocrisie d'avoir julian assange
justement qui pourrit en prison en
angleterre alors que justement il n'a
fait que dénoncer cette surveillance des
états alors washington s'est félicité de
cette décision et part d'un consensus
international sur ouais ouais
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il y à il ya
vraiment justement un consensus
international une attitude adopter
vis-à-vis de huawei vis-à-vis de la
chine en général depuis effectivement
changements de politiques américains sur
la chine
on sent effectivement une grande
crispation le problème c'est qu'il ya la
réalité la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui est produit en chine mais on l'a
vu avec la question de la souveraineté
pharmaceutique c'est à dire qu'en france
par exemple on a des médicaments comme
c'est plus produire qu'on n'a plus la
capacité de produire
on est obligé de passer par la chine est
en fait on a créé un monstre et
maintenant s'étonne que le monstre venu
manger
donc c'est un peu on va dire pour moi il
ya une espèce de dichotomie dans ce
langage là parce qu'effectivement et on
voit avec les états unis les états unis
tapez régulièrement très dur sur la
chine la chine fait un peu le dos rond
il y est décrit dans un peu les muscles
les etats-unis reviennent derrière parce
qu'ils se rendent compte tels que demain
ils auront plus tout bêtement de
sous-vêtements à m puisque tout est fait
en chine aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai qu'
on est un peu dans un peu comme les
petits chiens qui aboient beaucoup mais
qui meurt pas on sait que le géant
chinois est le leader mondial en matière
de 5 g et lancer cette nouvelle
génération d'internet mobile sans huawei
aura forcément des conséquences pour les
pays concernés quels sont les plus
importantes selon vous déjà pour moi
c'est surtout un nom
en cette technologie les standards sont
développées de manière globale faut
savoir que la plupart des standards type
la 5g sont développés en particulier par
les universités laboratoires publics
avec des conglomérat d'entreprises qui
participent à ces consortiums de
recherche
mais la réalité c'est effectivement que
à la base et un effort généralement
internationale pour développer la norme
or la chine a très vite pris l'ascendant
sur les autres pays qui tergiversait et
faute de politique industrielle de plans
on va dire industriels sur du long terme
n'a pas su saisir l'opportunité a
attendu et les chinois sont on va dire
c'est un peu le le fameux discours du
premier prend tout marché c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait donc aujourd'hui
effectivement on s'en plaint mais
c'était à nous d'avoir l'outil
industriel capable de rivaliser avec les
chinois au louvre en france on a vendu
alcatel à nokia nokia qui maintenant
bradley toutes les parties d'alcatel qui
est très en retard sur cette question
d'un singe et on aurait pu être au même
niveau que les chinois puisque on a les
connaissances on a les compétences on a
les vivier d'ingénieurs ici pour le
faire mais on a laissé faire parce que
effectivement probablement quelqu'un un
jour à regarder sur un excellent et
s'est dit ah bah c'est moins cher que ce
soit faire en chine et s'est jamais posé
ces questions on va dire de surveillance
de souveraineté des deux propre
technologie et ce problème là on va
l'avoir enfance ses terres car moment-là
devoir choisir entre la peste et le
choléra
c'est que ce que entre justement à être
surveillé par les services secrets
chinois ou les services secrets
américains et ce sera pas une solution
donc mais un monde
merci beaucoup pedro voyages d'avoir un
étau d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable
numérique du mouvement république